that like by the way that picture of his poll requests into the
Monero repo was infinitely like a thousand times more consequential
than every single book he just spent like a minute pulling out.
It is I can't transport my knowledge into other people's brains.
So I want to make sure that this is as readable. We're going to
come up with a language, you know, we're going to speak the same
language to each other. Wild guess this video is going to be
dog. I straight up don't trust a dude who has C++ experience
in the quantitative trading space. I don't believe anybody in
that space gives a about coding structure. You could still use
alarms by for loop instead of manually setting alt to zero with
eight lines. Those were set to zero because it was ending the
alarms. By setting them to zero, you're actually setting the
alarm to off. You would know that if you've ever used game maker.
Yeah, but they were literally
Uh we all know the background. Okay. Pirate Software is a Nepo
baby narcissist. Okay. Tried to stop games. Tried to break Lucari's
spirit and only fangs. He is just a piece of [__]
Okay. Lied to Dr. K. Couldn't couldn't see his own faults. We
know everything about this guy. We can just skip to the code
review. Okay. Why Pirate Software? Now, why am I picking on for
here in particular? Well, Thor has not only what appears to be
lied about his experience or at the very minimum played it off
as something that it's really not, but he's also misrepresented
the initiative and has doubled and tripled down in that So, the
funny thing about this is probably not going to be this part,
guys. Okay? It's probably going to be his responses because I'm
guessing this guy will have like I'm guessing this guy will have
things to say and Thor's response is I'm guessing [__]
for something we want to start converse to legislation and these
are the reasons for not only can I agree with the initiative
but I can't agree with you and I won't agree with Ross. There's
no way around that. I think this is gross to sum it all up. No,
I will not be supporting the initiative stop games cryptically
wishing for the movement to So I'm gonna be honest with you.
That's not cryptic. What do you mean cryptic? That's direct.
That's directly being I don't support that. That seems weird.
This seems bad. I will not support it. Hi.
No crypticness. You know this guy's names per chance? He looks
like someone I just went to school with. Uh, no. No idea. Aim's
just coding Jesus, bro. I hope that your initiative gets everything
you asked for, but nothing you wanted. I don't know why you do
that, but he decided to do so. He doesn't even have to agree
with the movement. He just needs to admit that he misrepresented
it. Now, other creators have reviewed this drama to no end and
have gone over his employment history and timeline. Developer
exam is pirate software part one job history and development
hell.
Yeah, we went over this his LinkedIn. What I want to do that
I guess would make this video unique is go over his actual code
from his developer live streams and analyze whether this guy
has the skills that he claims he has as a 20-year veteran and
game developer working for Blizzard and other game publishers,
etc. My name is Jason Thor. What does he What does he say? Because
this is be pretty scummy too and something that I haven't noticed
but he probably does, right? where he sort of he's a game developer
now and he worked at Blizzard, but he never mentions that he
was not even close to like video games or working on video games
at Blizzard. He did like network stuff. I think he did like uh
exploits and GMing at Blizzard, right? And then he did like physical
on-site security, not like not like security in the games. I
don't even think he he might not have even done I think he ran
just like um antiche stuff like he he was like somebody who used
the antiche software. I don't believe he even coded the anti-che
software if I remember correctly. Also known as pirate software
online. I've been in the gaming industry for No, not a badge
checker, but he would have been one of the people who set up
like the like he would have been it kind 20 years. I used to
work at Blizzard Entertainment, then Amazon Game Studios, and
now I own my own studio, Pirate Software by the same name, which
is an indie studio, and I've been here for about 8 years now.
Now, why should you guys listen to me about any of this? Well,
I'm a C++ developer with 5 years of experience in the quantitative
trading space. I've read dozens of books on C++ and over half
a doz.
Okay. Uh, wild guess. This video is going to be dog.
I straight up don't trust a dude who has C++ experience in the
quantitative trading space. I don't believe anybody in that space
gives a about coding structure. I you will get people who like
format
5 years a 5 years is okay. You can be a really good coder after
5 years. You can have like solid opinions after 5 years. But
can can he sync his audio? His audio gets fixed apparently pretty
close. But I just don't believe that a C++ coder of five years
in a nonsoftware space I I just I don't believe that this will
be like a sensical code review. We'll see. He really just critiques
Yeah, but I could I could try to critique other things. C++ design.
This means nothing. I literally have never once met somebody
who actually knows what they're doing who is like, well, I read
this book and this book and this book. This is already major
red flags. Okay, BB Poison. You ever meet a really good coder
who's like, "Hey, you should check out this book on coding styles,
right? On on style guides, it'll really help you with style guides.
I've never ever What animals were on the cover of your books?"
Oh, this is like O'Reilly books and all of O'Reilly books just
have like an animal on the cover. They're pretty famous. No,
the books aren't necessarily bad. The books can actually be good.
Especially you're picking up a new language. Okay. Oh, man. You
guys ever seen um you guys ever seen Learn You a Haskell?
This is cool. This is like a fun book that somebody made for
free online. Learn you a Haskell for for great good. This is
actually a really good book for learning a functional programming
language. If you want to start with Haskell,
um this is a really good book. Okay, it's fun. Okay, it's fun.
It's cool. And it's got little little drawings and doodles all
over it. Okay, and they're actually informative and helpful.
This is basically one of the only programming books I've ever
found super helpful. I took a functional programming class in
university. I used this guide to learn Haskell and I was like
miles ahead of everybody else. It was like insane. Destiny tried
to learn C++ on stream. Apparently there's good memes there at
JTO. I heard he failed Hello World. I I'm probably not going
to find it super meaningful to be honest. Now learn some Go.
I know Go.
I can abs I could co code Go right now almost certainly after
not doing it for like two years.
Uh, I wrote, what did I write? I wrote like a transcript grabber
and
I had that pipe over to like a log searcher because I was trying
to make like a YouTube log search thing kind of like um I was
just trying to make like filot basically. I basically made Filot,
right? And the back end for that that I was running like mostly
to do stuff was in Go and it wasn't even like a it shouldn't
have even been a Go application. It was like um just using Cobra
to bring it build a command line for myself.
Anyway, nobody knows what that means, but I do. Good luck. Then
one or two programming languages should be able to pick up any
language relatively quickly. And well, I think declarative languages
instead of imperative languages, right? Declarative languages,
if you can learn a declarative language, I feel like these are
very very helpful for just understanding abstract concepts,
right? If you can learn a declarative language and actually write
a like some even like remotely sensical programs in them, declarative
languages are like um I don't even know how to describe the difference.
It's basically like you set up definitions and then the the compiler
like infers from those definitions all the things you basically
say like here are the rules of the program I'm writing and it's
like it works whereas um imperative languages you basically write
individual instructions you go this is what I want you to do
if this then that is an imperative language in a lot of ways
right that's almost certainly too simplified but um but declarative
languages are different they're goofy man I took I took a class
on this in school and I never got to do the compilers class.
I wish I would have cuz I think all compilers essentially are
written in declarative languages. Usually not Haskell though.
None of you know what I'm talking about. None of you care. None
of you are interested. It's just me yapping to myself and like
five other coders in the chat. But that's okay. That's okay.
That's okay. Anyway, back to the video. Influencers on in the
space to professors to people that also have YouTube channels
to time and I think I read this book. Yeah, I read this book.
Parts of this book at least. This is like good if you're doing
like um like basically like
large scale Java and took time.
Books are pretty bad. Yeah, BB Poison. I don't know if you just
heard me rant about this is like the only book I've ever used
like to any substantial degree to learn a language or anything
coding
Books are basically like you're learning stuff that's so old
if you're in books that you don't really care or it's like it's
just outdated knowledge.
Books are like the worst medium to carry like programming knowledge.
Anyway,
contested and trusted books. I've read a lot. And while I'm not
an authority, the art of writing, dude, this is like the worst.
I don't know if you were here, BB Poison. I said like this is
this is actually like the worst credentials. He's just showing
me all of the books he read and why he can like do this video,
but nobody cares. Also, he works in finance. I just know his
code's going to be awful. in C++. I'm pretty likely to be somebody
that can sus out a bad practice if I see one. At least I hope.
I also have a bunch of open source contributions in C++ on pro.
Oh, this is way better. projects that I find interesting like
Monero.
Now, when I was that like, by the way, that picture of his pull
requests into the Monero repo was infinitely like a thousand
times more consequential than every single book he just spent
like a minute pulling out. Just to be clear with everybody
that's Did he Did he Were any of those purple? Were any of those
merged? Yeah, he's got one, two, three, four merges. though five
merges on projects that I find interesting like
Now when I was making notes for this but commits into the core
of Monero even not going to convince me you write C++ with solid
video cuz I like to come prepared. I thought I need to go through
dozens of his pull request into the Monero repo. Monero is a
cryptocurrency. Okay, Monero is a cryptocurrency.
Um this is GitHub. This is what you would call a version control
system. Okay. So this is basically how you add and replace lines
of text in files in code files. Okay. And you can do so in a
way that it keeps a history of all changes that have ever been
made to a program. And then there's a website called GitHub where
you can host this version control stuff and host your repository
of like some program. Okay. Monero cryptocurrency. So he has
basically submitted changes to this cryptocurrency and how it
works and
Yeah. So, and it seems like some of them were accepted by the
broader community that works on this on this
Now, there wallet RPCs. Uh, this seems like fine. What does coding
have to do with pirate being a Oh, this is a this is like a review
of his like a review of all of his subjects that I find interesting
like Monero.
Now when I was oh and pull request is so when you go to submit
some new update to the code you'll update basically in like a
patch file which basically says okay I removed these lines I
modified these lines I added these lines and the patch file will
be merged into the system which it'll basically
it'll update every line you've changed or if there have been
changes to those lines since you last pulled since you last like
downloaded the the entire codebase it'll tell you where there's
conflicts right so it's so multiple people can work on the same
set of text files at the same time. So pull request is saying
hey I have like a patch that I want to apply here would you review
all of the changes other people and so that we can get this accepted
and put into the main codebase. I think that that's somewhat
close to an explanation. It probably doesn't work for everybody
but making notes for this video because I like to come prepared.
I thought I need to go through dozens of different developer
streams. But what I found out really quickly is that I can only
find two developer streams that Thor actually brings up code
on the screen in. And in those developer streams, he one does
not actually do any coding. The code is just visually there on
the screen. And 90 Honestly, it might be funnier watching JST
react to Chud watching this video trying to understand coding
and making his best guess for the sake of the content. No, I'm
good. I'll watch this. 8% of the actual stream is him looking
at his subscribers, looking at his tip jar as to how much money
people have sent him, and also looking at videos about games,
but never actually doing any game development in a dev stream.
Without further ado, let's actually take a look at some of his
code. All right, so I'm going to be linking these VODs in the
description box below. I recommend people actually download the
Is this actually C++ or is this going to be like Game Maker language?
before he takes them down because honestly if I was claiming
I'm a game developer with 20 years of experience oh you actually
went to school with this this would be embarrassing to have
what's really wrong about this and I don't even need to be a
game dev to understand that when you look at the code here what
do you see you see a lot of magic numbers that's an industry
term for numbers
that don't have any description or explanation as to what they
are or why they exist and you also have a lot of true or false
which is not descript descriptive at all when you look at any
Oh, he's going to do he's going to do a bunch of things that
he's going to do like a bunch of here where I don't magic numbers.
Sure. The magic numbers here may be bad. I don't know. There's
a decent chance that the magic numbers here are somewhat descriptive
effect drop. Like you might not get anything out of setting up
constants for all these things to actual actually script kitty
while actually. Yeah. like
the whole point of setting up a magic. So basically what he's
saying here is when you have like a one here, you don't know
why you're using a one there. And so what you would do is you
create what you call a constant. And a constant would just be
this number would be one, but you'd say it would get a a name.
So you could just name a variable to put in this in this place.
People say, "Oh, you shouldn't have magic numbers." You can set
up style guides where you don't have numbers like this. Cuz basically,
if you want to change them, you might want to use So, here's
the thing. For for part type size or something, you might want
to use this one. Like, let's say this was um Oh, what would be
a good one? Let's say like you're writing a calculator and you
have like pi, you'd want pi to be something that's named because
you wouldn't want to write out as many points of pi as you can
everywhere, right? You just want to define pi, put it in a variable
that can't change, and then you know it's there.
All right. So the idea of a magic number is if you were putting
pi everywhere, then if you update pi somewhere, if you were to
change it somewhere, that wouldn't update in all the other places
you use it. So you have a constant, you have it like referenced
from somewhere where you can change it and it will change in
like 85 different places. Right now, right here, falling particle,
I don't know if particle type size 1. I don't know if you'll
ever use the falling particle size anywhere else. So actually
the magic numbers here might be totally fine,
right? as far as I can tell that like unless you're using going
to use this in multiple places like for games and this will throw
so many people through a loop because for game making like there's
a lot of um like singleton type entities or like entities that
are like you're defining stuff and it's only going to be written
once and you know it's only going to be written once. Like if
you're defining particle effects, yeah, there's probably only
going to be the places where those numbers are going to be relevant.
So there might not be any reason to go and define constants for
all of this. You just look for
any function call as another developer, you should understand
what's going on without needing to read through the implementation
of the actual method itself. So part type sprite, part type.
I can infer from context that these are not his, right? Or at
least I I feel like there's almost no way these could be his
functions. These have to be engine functions, right? Guys, I
don't need to read through that to understand what's being passed
to it and what it's doing. But that's not what's going on here.
I shouldn't need to ask myself what is this number one? What
is the zero? What does it signify? Right? Imagine we have a car
object and I create the car object by passing. This is like okay,
what does it signify?
This is like I'll give you an example. Let's say um oh man, there'd
be a good mathematical function I could use, but I can't think
of one. Basically like a math function. You you don't really
you can just use like a max function or a min function, a ceiling
function, right? You don't necessarily need all the par all the
variables um written down. Oh, let's say uh let's say Malo, right?
Malik or Kelloc in see in C. Yeah. Yeah. Allocations. So there
would be there would be language specific
allocation functions that you would never ever be concerned about
not understanding what they mean because you use them all the
time, right? So if you have a four parameter function that allows
you to allocate memory and see, you're always going to know what
those things are. You don't really need to do whatever the [__]
is going on here. 96 four false.
Do you have any idea about what those numbers mean? No, but that's
that's totally different. These are actual language function
or sorry, these are I I believe like engine
How am I initializing that car? You don't. A step above that
a better alternative would be to specify in words what 96 means.
for example. Yeah, this would be this would be such a dude. Actually,
there's no way everybody got tricked, is there? This isn't Unity.
It's game maker language. This guy's already totally This guy's
actually already totally out to lunch. This is like actually
stupid.
This guy's just suggested so many things
in like two seconds. This guy is just said so many things. I
would argue right now this is not subjective. Okay,
I don't think it's subjective. I think he is way overcooking
it here. I think this is like absolutely ridiculous at this point.
Unsigned 32bit integer horsepower equals 96. Number of doors
equals 4. Is automatic equals false. Is electric equals false?
And then pass that into the construction of car. That is the
bare minimum.
That
No, it's not the bare. What?
Dude, somebody go get me the the code for like Super Hexagon
or the code for um somebody go get me the source code for Bellatro.
Let's go look at the source code for Batro right now. Okay. I
I feel like people
a lot of these are all assumptions based on I need my code to
be as re human readable for the next person working on it as
possible. I'm working on like a 100 person team, right? And I
need it to be human readable for all these people. This is a
single dev indie game. I don't think there's any argument for
this. Didn't people show the blotro dev? Yeah, because they're
yes, I can defend the blotro code. Okay, I maybe not how it's
organized, but it's not like it's not like up that badly.
It's like up way less badly than a lot of people think it is.
I don't know coding, but conceptually, would he be more inclined
to think this way because he works in finance? No. No. This is
just basic like um this is like baby's first style guide basic.
This This sounds like a university student who's telling me how
I should code is what it sound like. Plus, the only benefit from
this guy's points would be only apply if roach software is on
a team. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. You place your abstractions at
different places to solve different problems. He's not doing
any actual analysis, just nitpicking style issues. Yeah, exactly
right. And that's that's actually Gucci Jesus's that's I think
the big issue with people's criticism of the Blotro code is I
think further abstracting things doesn't help. People hate this.
There's this concept in video games where you define a lot of
like entities a single time, right? And people don't like because
a bunch of CC coders do this when they just put it in a massive
dictionary. They'll just do or a massive switch statement, right?
Like a switch statement is basically just a dictionary. They'll
have a massive switch statement and they'll be like, "Oh, for
jokers, it's jokers in the Blotro case, right? Oh, I'm going
to have like all of my jokers in one massive switch statement."
And people will get mad about that. They will get very upset
about it. But actually there's no abstraction past the dictionary
that really works well for this. You can put your dictionary
in different places. You could write it in like a static YAML
file. You could write it in an actual dictionary structure. You
could write in a switch statement. You could write if this if
this then uh if not like you could just write if else for like
a ton of if else.
If if this else if this else if this you could do that, right?
And technically when you go down to the compiler it's all the
same thing. And there aren't really super like amazing abstractions
past that. But uh I think I think in Batro the um in Bellatro
I think it's just that it's a switch statement and people hate
that. And I'm like dude that's that's literally if you're if
you have a big dictionary full of things that are totally different,
don't rely on each other at all. That's the way it goes, bro.
That's how she go. Anyway,
that's what I would expect out of an intern that's fresh out
of school. Taking that a step further, you can implement a concept.
Bro, I this is 42,000 views. Oh my god, this is actually so goofy
that like I I thought this was like people are saying this is
like a massive own on pirate software called
I should let the video play which is the most expressive form
of instantiation.
What we can do in that case is define an alias at the bare minimum
or a class and we can call it horsepower
and then we can create an Yeah, this is all super
he has no he has no idea if any of these will ever be used anywhere
else at all and they're all being used for the same types of
functions that are all around creating
for things like trans. Is this even possible in GML? Is it? I
have no idea. But like this is all just [__] around
particles mission or fuel. And then we'd alter the car's constructor
and pass in that information. Horsepower 98, door number four,
transmission automatic, fuel gasoline. So this can be nice and
some languages do this for you, right? Where like Python does
this where you can name like you basically give it named parameters.
Named parameters are nice. If your language doesn't support name
parameters and it's like a game making language
and that's fine.
I would guess that whatever editor this is that it's very expressive.
Not here, but if you click on any of these lines that it would
probably tell you the parameters, right? You can be a game like
you even click on the one here and it's probably going to pop
an editor
tool tip up and tell you what the developer to know that that's
a lot more maintainable
than whatever Thor has here.
Another really good example of that is at 2556.
So if we jump there.
Okay. Right here. Alarm zero, alarm one, alarm two. What is that?
What are those alarms? Is it an alarm for person A? An alarm
for whatever character. An alarm to do what? It's unexpressive.
It's I've got no idea what this is. This does look like it's
goofy. This does look like but really spaghetti code in my opinion.
Okay. as let's go to around 1 hour with a single person project.
This is also a complete pirate responds as if he got owned and
his answers are strange as dude. I was just going to say somebody
said wait until you see pirate's response and I'm like dude if
he like is so that he thinks um that he thinks this guy like
made good points. Although now that we're getting a little further
if question true equals 1 and question asked equals zero. Oh,
this does seem very weird a little bit, but I mean again, it's
a single mess for a couple of reasons. First of all, Thor is
using the incorrect data types. This isn't even getting to some
sort of advanced design or design pattern. It's showing a clear
complete lack of understanding how to represent information in
a program. Okay, what do I mean by that? Well, look at question
asked equals zero. Question asked in my opinion is true or false.
Has this question been asked? It should be a boolean data type.
What does zero mean? Booleans are represented as integers under
the hood. So in C++, anything that isn't zero is true. So one
is true. But why would you even give another developer the option
to write question asked equals 42. In theory, that should be
true
because anything other than zero is true. But why even allow
somebody to write code that can potentially is this guy like
not aware that this is Hold on. Oh, it's true false like this.
Okay. I was like, dude, why are you
Why are you saying this when you don't know? He just didn't know
cuz it's possible that a language could represent it that way
or like that there may be like in C.
I believe I believe true and false are aliases to zero and one,
right? Did he just say that? He might have just said that actually.
He said under the hood representals.
Anyway, in theory, that should be true because anything other
than zero is true. But why even allow somebody to write code
that can potentially be that confusing? It's just a no-go.
Another thing here that I noticed is the absurd amount of comments.
Most of the time, you don't need to write comments in your code.
That's because your code should be self-documenting.
But there is a 1 to 5% case rate in which you should be writing.
Maybe, maybe. Okay,
I think sometimes things can be complicated and you can
my favorite, dude. My favorite comment. Okay, I don't write comments
very often, but my favorite comment to put into a PR
this is I can't think of like a better way to do it right now,
so go ahead and like at me if you fix it. I think I've written
that in some places. I'm like not I use like more professional
language, but I I know like sometimes I'm like doing something
it's like complex and I'm like, "Hey, this is like really bad.
If you know a better way to do it, make sure you tell me cuz
I actually don't know."
Comments only if your code is extreme
uh complex and that's not the case here. This is a simple if
statement and a simple switch statement.
You don't need to add comments here. Having a comment,
but we have asked the question and question asks equals one is
totally superfluous, a waste of time, a waste of space. I'm not
sure what why it was added if if not just to waste time on a
dev stream to spend more time pretending you're coding than watching
videos. That's actually Hold on. I feel like that's how that
got written.
I think
that I I feel like I believe that this would be him like literally
asking questions to himself about like like maybe he was coding
on stream and was not getting the result he wanted and so he
started like documenting what he was Okay, let's take a look
at his second stream because the rest of this stream is reviewing
other games,
looking at his subscription count. I don't know why he gets so
etc. Okay, here he appears to be storing a timeline of events
in a flat one-dimensional array with random numbers as the indices
in order to represent set event. So
literally anything would be an upgrade over what is written here.
For example, what he could have done is created a nested structure
where all those default values instead of being hard-coded and
written in some file can simply be stored in a YAML or configuration
file that could be edited. Why? What does that abstraction give
you? What that's so this is the most common. This is like every
single game developer always gets this criticism and some like
three-year developer comes along and goes, "You're going to actually
put that in a YAML file." I know you guys have heard me say this
to people on stream. Oh, you can actually put that in a YAML
file. Why does it matter how you store your dictionary? Why?
It's still a dictionary. Every everything there when you write
a YAML file, it's going to take that and then put it into memory
for you later. You're going to have to read that YAML file. It's
it's just outside of the build as to not waste time rebuilding
the entire application
in a YAML or XML format.
That's development 101. You load it in the first week of your
new job as either. So that is a good point that you could technically
load it from outside of the application. That lets you through
version control update it through outside of the outside of the
application and do all of that. That's a good point.
So you won't have to recompile. I'm trying to think. So that's
good for cloud deployments. Really good. I'm trying to think
of if I necessarily want to do that in my own program. If I want
to load the YAML file. I've never thought so. I thought that
didn't really apply to games, but now I'm thinking and that might
actually be a better point than I was giving it credit for. I'm
trying to think of how long it would take you to recompile in
Game Maker. Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Hold
on. That probably saves you some compile time, but you'll still
have to unless you write something that updates it automatically,
that's like that's like viewing that YAML file to update, you
would still have to rebuild, right? Assuming you pull it in,
you'd have to have some system for pulling it in on the fly to
like hot swap. Yeah, you're an intern or a junior developer.
What's even worse is he now also needs to remember what 419 means.
So somewhere in his code, he needs to actually add
a comment or something to represent what a 419 is. As you can
see here, I found the file that contains all these events which
are the association between an object number and some state.
It's very obvious that this can get very unwieldy extremely quickly.
As you can see here, he has some number associated with 0, one,
or even two. And then he needs to detail in a comment what that
means. Now imagine a developer accidentally puts two here or
three. So
what would you do normally? There's like a couple different ways
you could do this. Like if you
find I'm trying to think of would these work as different. I'm
trying to think of if you benefit from some structure here beyond
this.
There might be some way to benefit from some some structure here.
Pool pull. Pool 012 pool 01. No. Yes. I'd have to look more at
this to see what's reusable. ing tracking and solving that bug
is really going to be a development nightmare. A dictionary would
be an improvement. I mean, a dictionary
could be an improvements. What do we have for dictionaries here?
Hold on. Are you going to be able to Why is this not Thank you.
Oh, no. Not working like that. Hold on. Game Maker manual. Let's
check it out. Game Maker language. Game Maker code. Game Maker
code reference. Data structures.
Maps. App index. Key. Oh, I'm not a fan of how these look. So,
I was thinking he could have like some structure he defines for
each one, like a unique structure for each of the scenes, but
it seems like they've got different uh attributes to them. I
have to think of how I wanted to do this, right? Honestly, for
what you save having these like explicit indices, although that's
technically like a speed improvement, you're never going to have
enough storylines
that that's going to matter, right? Like you have this in like
a a tree dict
like hashtdict. It's not going to is not going to take you a
long time to go through this, right? So, you could all could
solve the ARG.
What if you forget to type three here and it accidentally type
two and start associating coffee cold knowledge with floor 2
coffee age? Or even worse, in your code somewhere, instead of
typing 213, you type 214 and now need to go back and track why
your game is. So, this is probably this is probably a good good
point. How could you do this? Um, you could also just define
what do you call like constants for each of these, right?
In some other place. That's what this is, right? Just do constants.
You do your own map.
I think constants here would be good so that you basically have
this like as a named thing and that when you reference it somewhere
else, you make sure you don't [__] it up. Like you
said, this is extremely poor practice and can get very messy
very quickly.
Not only that, but this is going to significantly decrease.
So, you could use an enum. Oh, right, right, right. Yeah, obviously
use an enim. Yeah, my
Oh, where would we have an enum here? Wouldn't be under data
structures, right? Can I just search this? You got enimrs for
me? You do. You do. You do. You do. You do. Yeah, you got enumerated
types. So, you could just do this. Yes, he should have done an
enume for this. Yeah, 100%. God, I have not. this would all come
back to me, but I have not coded as a job for like since I started
like probably
like like five months into streaming. Four months into streaming
was when I was making enough money that I was like, "Oh, I'll
try this."
So, I've like Yeah, I've done the velocity of your development
because you're going to need to jump between the storyline vars
file, find the event you want to reference somewhere else in
code, and go back to that line that you'd like to reference the
event in. So, you're going to constantly need to be jumping between
files, forgetting, potentially mistyping,
and it's just a recipe for disaster. Why not use a huge Well,
I mean, technically, what is a dictionary if not um if not a
map of key value pair, if not like an array where these are just
named, right? Where the where the keys are named. That's what
a dictionary is, right? That's you you essentially get that thing.
dev cycle has changed with AI quite a bit I would imagine. So
I was already using AI and before that but like I think I had
already started using code pilot and stuff like that. So when
it comes to the nested structure though tell me what you think
is better what Thor has here or what I have on screen which in
my opinion is much more expressive. Now this goes beyond simply
liking this is expressive but it like it might just be overkill
for a single person project. Like again, you're defining things
that seem to be single use. If I I would have to know exactly
how this is laid out and how it like tracks to know if there's
things that get reused. I don't necessarily like creating stuff
like this when there's no reusability and when I don't when I
know that there won't be reusability. Like these are states.
These are individual states as you progress through his game,
right? These are like states for different scenes. It's like
a story- based game. You're not going to be re-entering these
places a whole bunch or if you do it'll be like you'll reload
it for that one scene and it will just be whatever state you
had. Code better. What I have on screen is objectively better
because it makes it harder for you and others to make mistakes
and it's a lot clearer as to what's going on. I don't even need
to know how this game is designed to understand that whatever
he's doing here is not optimal. I also don't need to re recommend
the most optimal data structure because literally anything would
be better than this. Another thing that's really really I think
as long as you had um like some named key value for each of these
cuz he he makes a good point that it just could get confusing
or you could like mistype here. You could like accidentally edit
this and then it's like not even remotely clear. weird is that
he's using these numbers to represent people and now everywhere
he writes the number one and when it represents a person he needs
to remember that it's Shelly. There's another case for any name
which is presumably a game character.
Imagine removing all these comments.
Would you as a newly added game developer to his game project
have any idea that one is Shelly?
You would have no idea. This would never ever be allowed in a
production repository
and like I like I'm I've been hinting it's below what you'd expect
of a bottom tier intern. One way to improve this is to write
case and then switch on an enumeration. So case character anytime
you're using a switch statement,
You probably should be using I think this is like actually strictly
enforced by some style guides and some like auto style scripts.
Like literally if you are or some llinters, right? Like llinters
will literally throw an exception and say, "Hey, you're doing
a switch without some enumerated type here yourself." Very disturbing
when they tell you to give yourself your llinter, you know? Or
Shelly, you guys get it. way way better to whatever he has here.
Another example is at 159
more magic numbers 32. What does message 32 mean? What does message
65 mean? What does message 97 mean? And what are these dialogue
options 2 5 6 0? These this is a culmination of my past couple
of comments all in one steaming pile of. Surprisingly,
that is all the code that I can literally if Pirate Software
was using enums, I think this entire code base improved significantly
with not a lot of not a lot of work to go into it to be
Find in these game. We'll see. The enim stuff is good. All of
the from the beginning that was dog the enim stuff
um or whatever he's talking about using strrus like I I think
that's reasonable with the the states that could get confusing
and do a lot of jumping back and forth and not good. Let's see
how this looks in his
Okay, I've got this like one response
Okay, this Oh, it's never used Game Maker Studio doesn't know
Game Maker language and talked a lot of Oh no. Oh no.
Oh no.
My workplace has a legacy code base where there are no way where
there is no way are no ways to express uh or write key value
pairs only arrays. So I get triggered by code overusing/misusing
arrays.
Yeah. I mean if you have enumerated types and you can and you
can like name constants that's to me that's basically like a
dictionary. You have like named keys that map onto values right
going into your array.
Anyway sh was wrong. Pretty funny.
Should look at my comment underneath his video. Imagine screaming
and we should look at his comment underneath the video. What?
Where's it at, bro? Oh, was he? He literally had it pop up here,
didn't he? About alarms and Game Maker saying why aren't they?
Imagine screaming and about alarms and Game Maker saying Imagine
screaming this video. Imagine screaming Oh, it didn't pop up.
Am I crazy? I thought it popped up in this video. Pretty funny.
Should look at my
Oh, no. saying, "Why aren't these renamed when you literally
can't rename them?" He shows it later. Okay. Okay. Wild behavior.
It's just another like YouTube grifter trying to bite for relevance.
It's all that is insane behavior, dude. All too common these
days. Think you saw that one? Very strange. Yeah, it's nuts,
dude. You could still use alarms by for loop instead of manually
setting all to zero with eight lines. Those were set to zero
because it was ending the alarms. By setting them to zero, you're
actually setting the alarm to off. You would know that if you've
ever used Game Maker.
And that wasn't all of the alarm. Wait, and
it was some of them. So yeah, but they were literally
There'd be no reason to set that to a for loop. Can't see your
comment. Did he delete it? That'd be even funnier. You deleted
the comment. That would be even funnier. No, it's still there.
Yeah, I wrote this underneath this video. I said, "It's clear
you've never used GameMaker before based on your comments. Here's
a quick rundown for you. Uh, Sprite Spark is not a magic number.
It's a direct reference to an asset file called Sprite Spark.
This is how Game Maker allowed." Yeah, he wasn't using it. Sprite
Spark. He wasn't looking at sprite spark as a magic number. Allows
you to link sprites and other assets. When you want to use a
sprite, sound, or other object, you call it by name. The functions
you called out are part type create are built in. Oh, he's lucky.
So, pirate software is being on the part where he should be,
right? Like those comments about the the magic numbers were stupid.
You to define a particle. The functions below this directly reference
different aspects of this particle effect. These cannot be modified.
No, I think when he says sprite spark, I think that's not really
what the guy was pointing to as a magic number. He's pointing
to all the ones, zeros, threes that are around in those in those
uh particle creation functions. But this one was not I don't
think the guy pointed to this as a magic number that sprites,
but they can be wrapped. But this wouldn't be efficient. Having
them exposed as normal allows you to modify existing particles
dynamically, meaning in runtime while the effect is running.
Changing this just creates layers of obfiscation without improving
you. Oh, wait. Can you hot write code in Game Maker language
and it just like auto recompiles
while the game is running? Oh, that's kind of neat. That changes
a little bit. Usability or performance. Alarms are internal to
individual objects and only reference that same object that they're
inside of. When you see alarm zero, it's hitting the alarm zero
on the left side of the object there. We cannot rename these
as as they are tied. I try to put tied to the object they are
placed in. Cool typo. Setting an alarm zero causes that alarm
to stop. Think of this as a timing or delay function. Uh data
types are not defined in Game Maker. You cannot define a boolean.
You can use 01 or true false. It will. It doesn't do anything.
Wait, there's a Wait, what? None of this matters.
Cannot define a boolean. Oh, was he saying define a boolean?
There's a there's like a bool type in the language. You could
say true,
right? I think we looked this up. It's literally a bull type
which will attempt to convert a given value to oh no no hold
on wait why why does it pop up with that and then it doesn't
go to
oh maybe there isn't
variable is a boolean true or false
I mean there are there are booleans in the
I don't know you might it might be a dynamically typed language
right might just be dynamically typed so you might
go on the fly the array of the save files to create a
Oh, GML is dynamically typed. So, you just say this thing equals
true or false. So, realistically, it doesn't super matter. You're
not saving anything technically. But
yeah, it's fine. Uh, dynamically typed languages mean when you
define a variable, when you define a box to put some piece of
data in, it will automatically assume the size and shape of the
first thing you put in it. Okay? So, you don't actually define
things. You don't actually say what type they are. or you don't
say what box the variable is. The first thing you put in the
box is how it knows what variable it is. Um as opposed to there
are other languages like C, the language this guy writes in,
which are statically typed,
right? So you define things with that with that type. Um you
can still usually define things statically typed in a dynamically
typed language, but it doesn't structure for reverse engineer
engineers trying to solve the ARG behind the game. It also the
way for the save file is to create a workable structure for reverse
engineers trying to solve the energy behind the game. Oh.
Uh, are people trying to like decompile this to do some like
ARG with the game? I mean, I doubt anybody is because it's like
a 10-year-old game, but maybe there's some relevancy there.
Quintio and coding Jesus mentioned in the policy docs there is
a wait, what policy docs? in the response to this. There's a
reason to use true false for bull types instead of 01.
Well, I would imagine that you when you use 01, you probably
default to like a 16 bit integer and when you use true false,
you probably defi default to like an 8 bit integer or something
even smaller. Whatever the word size, whatever the word size
would be probably still I think I think C usually defines them
as eight like uh unates, right? Check the data types page. There's
documentation on boolean there. Okay, hold on.
Wait, did I There we go. Game maker manual. Let's go.
Let's go. Okay, hold on. Data types. Data types. Data types.
Code reference. Not variable functions. Data structures. Do we
have a type thing here that I just missed? A functions. Code
overview.
Oh, data types.
Boolean. True or false? And the game maker will interpret a real
number equal to or below 0.5 as false value. and any real number
greater than 0.5 as being true. This does not mean however that
you should be checking one or zero one and zero or any other
real number for true and false as you are provided with the constants
true and false which should always be used in your code to prevent
any issues should real boolean data types be added in a future
update. You can convert any real oh so this doesn't say that
you have to do it. It's saying if we ever actually introduce
a boolean type that's not just a wrapped integer, then you shouldn't
actually use zero or one because then later on when we switch
all this uh it won't behave the same. But like realistically,
I don't know that I care super badly about that. It's although
working on Pirate Software's timelines, maybe he does have to
care about that. Like I I don't know how much Game Maker gets
updated, but
like they say they say, "Oh, you shouldn't do this." But it's
it's just surface level. It really I don't know. I didn't see
people failing and doing bad abstractions to this out in the
exact same order in the save file. You can read about the ARG
here. It's does it work? Here's the issue. His doesn't work.
His broken for a lot of reasons. Mostly because he's But I don't
think I don't think the true or false is zero or one fails to
work. Yeah, I I don't see why it would fail to work. We'll see
what the response says. Maybe I I don't see from this. I see
it say don't do it, but I don't see it saying it doesn't work.
See it saying it does work right now. And um but you shouldn't
Anyway, we continue. We continue with you. Maximus, thank you
for the This is the game I work on. So hard. Now, understand
something before I send you this link. Do not buy my game.
Watch my short. Why? Understand something. As a programmer, every
language is all of them are they're all bad. And that's why we
use so many of them because they're bad. No. Oh, dude. Why would
you link me this? I sent this to I saw this. I sent this to Rita.
I like had a meltdown. This is like the uh
We're just a bunch of wizards with weirdass spells that sometimes
work. We perform magic. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. You
choose a language based on what it's good at. You are not a you're
not magic. You pick it entirely like logically. You literally
there's not there should be no magic involved. Sometimes that
magic goes wrong. Sometimes we don't know why. Sometimes we do
know why. Sometimes it goes right. Sometimes we don't know why.
Sometimes we do know why. And that's just how it
No, that is not even remotely what if you if you feel this way,
you should find a different career. Well, I don't know. Maybe
you I don't know what the job landscape is for coders. Okay.
It might not be great. It might be quite bad out there. It's
hard for me to say. It's just a bunch of disingenuous arguments
put up in bad faith trying to make me look like I might need
to re the cool typo. Setting an alarm zero causes that alarm
to stop. Think of this as a timing or delay function. That's
like fine. It doesn't mean the way you did that was good at all.
Uh data types are not defined in Game Maker. You cannot define
a boolean. You can use 01 or true false. It will doesn't do anything.
None of this matters in this language. the array of I I understand
in the documentation they say don't do that. I
get so stupid. It's actually so dumb that I agree with them.
I don't want to agree with him. I don't like agreeing with him.
Okay. It upsets To create a workable structure for I don't think
that necessarily matters. His code looks like dog. Like I I don't
think I'd like reading his code. I wouldn't write code like that
Reverse engineer engineers trying to solve the ARG behind the
game. It also saves this out in the exact same order in the save
file. You can read about the ARG here. It's just a bunch of disingenuous
arguments put up in bad faith trying to make me look like a bad
programmer. And in reality, this guy has never used the engine
that I'm working in, never used the language that I'm working
with, and all of his points are moot as a result, you know. But
he's
bro that that that array that's just numbers. That seems like
like probably I think the Batro guy at least used some enumems
to uh define like things in his switch statement, right? I think
so. I don't remember for sure, but I think so. Sick internet.
Cutting Jesus released a 15-minute video reviewing you. Do you
see it by any chance? Yeah. And I wrote a gigantic comment on
it. We actually just went over it. Um Cutting Jesus obviously
has never worked in GameMaker Studio or with GameMaker language.
And he made a bunch of wild assumptions about the language and
things that should be changed or shouldn't be changed. And it's
very clear he doesn't know what he's talking about. So, I put
a large comment underneath this, but it got buried. Some of the
stuff was gross and myriad of other comments that you can see
here. Uh, so if you want to screenshot that, you can go and read
it yourself. We just went over it on stream. I don't want to
do this all stream to be honest with you. But yeah, uh, he's
obviously never worked in this language ever. So, even down to
like weird stuff like why are alarms named this way with magic
numbers? They're they're not they cannot be changed. The engine
won't allow you to.
Yeah. Wait, why are alarms named? I don't think he I think he
said probably there should be some structure. That would be another
case where you could use enums in that specific case. You don't
have to, but whatever. Am I just Python brain? Why would you
ever do if myvar equals equals false if if myvar Well, I have
no idea how conditionals work. I don't know if you can do conditionals
that way in Game Maker Studio. So, we'll just see expression
this will work. example
expression statement. But it looks like it looks like it's actually
testing true false like these would return
because they don't have a boolean type. You might actually have
to use the equals equals to imply that it's an expression, right?
So they don't have a boolean type in in this language. They have
like a wrapped thing. They have like a they have like constants
for true and false, but those constants for true and false are
like zero and one. They don't have a boolean structure. So I'm
guessing to make it an expression you have to use some um boolean
operator equals equals
um greater than less than greater than equal. Yeah,
it looks like this is basically well this is hold on this is
using like a would just be condition
seems to be doing it though. So it seems to be evaluating a here
just properly. So maybe you can and it just
can be values true or false target condition will be removed
from the code. Yeah, that's fine. That doesn't matter. Value
that is less than or equal to zero will evaluate as false while
any value that's greater than zero will evaluate as true. I don't
I don't actually know cuz they keep doing this and they're not
doing if tests. So I'm assuming you you need the equals equals.
But then the the other conditions although this just says condition
instead of expression, right? These are expressions up here.
So I'm guessing for it to qualify as an expression. Yeah. Yes.
Okay. I'm guessing that's what it is. Very cool.
What was the language you said? GML. It's called Game Maker language.
It is built in for Game Maker. Game Maker does not allow you
to use other languages. Fact that you didn't open GPT is how
I know you don't code anymore. Hacks. So as a result of this,
he doesn't know what he's talking about and he's about that is
not changeable inside of Game
I didn't get that impression.
You go back to the alarm section and see. I would expect a little
bit better from someone named coding Jesus. Hold on. Let let
me give you 2550
isn't zero.
You guys get the five.
I missed the alarm. Here it is.
Whatever character an alarm to do what? So these alarms here
start talking fade out. So you could have some way of tying I'm
guessing.
Oh man. So he's using these alarms here setting them to zero.
You could have an enum to say what these are. I tend to feel
like this actually looks not as bad. You could use this might
be defensible. This may be defensible. Yeah, Supreme. I I want
to say that I just like knowing things. It's just the easiest
way to do things. It's just look it up um without using something
that asks without asking something. We'll know instantly. I'm
good. If you don't if you don't like going looking manuals, gay,
that's fine. I tend to think like here's here's how this looks
in the code, right? Is he has this in the ID. I tend to feel
like on a oneperson project that actually is okay, right? This
might actually not be as bad as I thought it was the first time.
I think so. Oh man, that's it's a tough one cuz I I thought maybe
he could name these things, but you literally have alarm zero
is start talking. So it's like you're not going to necessarily
forget this. If you could somehow have this defined in code,
that would be nice, maybe. But uh feels like there should be
some way to define alarms on objects and like access this through
the code or something. I don't know. But I I again I don't know
the language. So
but I've got the ego, right? Very cool. Is he a webdev or something?
I have no idea. But he clearly doesn't know this language.
You can review languages. Many concepts concepts are transferable.
Concepts can be transferable but specifics are not. And that's
the problem. person called out a bunch of specifics
as they would in another language that are not correct in this
language. So no, you cannot code review correctly in a language
you don't know. To be fair, you haven't seen the array, but it
was the one solution you thought of off the top of your head.
Depending on how Yeah, but you would still have that problem.
Emer, right? I don't think that problem goes away if you delete
it and that like it flips things. How would how would having
an enum when it's not tied to like that list? How would that
even help? like unless there's a way to actually use those alarms.
I mean, we could just look it up.
One dimensional array is used to get the current value for any
alarms that the instance may have or it can be used to set those
alarms. There are 12 alarms built into each instance of an object
and each one has its own event that will run when the variable
reaches zero. Alarms are counted down at the start of each step.
Blah blah blah blah blah. Zero equals game get speed game speed.
Um, so this is doing like a cool down. Okay. I just wonder if
the alarm isn't running. Well, he's pausing the alarms. So, I
wonder who's not setting it to minus one. I tend to think that
like this is probably making sense and him setting them all to
zero could make sense. I don't know if zero is the right thing.
But this actually might be totally fine, but you only have to
change one place. Wait, there. So, this alarm thing is like a
built-in, right? You can't rename this alarm thing. What would
you want to do here? You'd set it to like a reference or something
and you'd use the reference in other places. I don't know if
you can do pointers to pointers like that in Game Maker. I don't
think I don't know if that necessarily works. Zero would be false.
How he does it, I'm guessing. No, it's not false.
What do you mean? These alarms are like they're like counting
down from some number. What you talking
The thing you change is the enume if at
Yeah, but these are all just on like an instance, right? You're
writing this on the script for an instance. Like, are you doing
a bunch of other really like uh complicated logic on these same
things? I don't even know
an enim for a key, but that would only matter if they could get
reordered. Um, yeah, I guess you'd have to look and see when
you delete what happens if it keeps the list the same way. But
then the enum would just have to be updated, right? Like you'd
have to go and delete from the enim as well. It'sive
and delete from the enum as well. You'd still have to do it in
two places now. Two places instead of potentially like eight
places. I guess I'm guessing alarms given that this is how the
documentation looks. I don't know if the alarms would be that
that way, but like you'd have to be using it in multiple places,
right? You'd have to see the rest of the code here to know how
the alarms are used to know that it would be valuable to even
do it. Really spaghetti code in my opinion. Okay, let's go to
around 1 hour. So, I'd say that shockingly I I didn't like this
either, but shockingly I I didn't look up the reference. I was
like, maybe.
But I think this is maybe fine. I I think I'm pretty good pretty
good to go here with this being fine. GPT just tells you even
less. Go use chat GPT. Go over this stuff yourself. I'm I'm good
with my process right now. I'm good. Good luck. I want to slap
you. You just were totally confused. How do you fix something
you haven't seen before? Stop it. Literally part of the problem.
God damn, dude. That's even funnier. You can see the comments.
Some people can't see it. Some people can see Times it tells
you the wrong answer. I I'll be honest. I haven't coded with
AI since LM's like it's got to be a year and a half ago or something,
right? So, I'm guessing LMS have gotten a lot better, but yes,
when I was coding with Copilot before, it would just hallucinate
functions that didn't exist. I had not used pandas a lot before
and it would hallucinate functions that didn't exist at all.
It was very goofy.
It was kind of annoying. I'm guessing it's better about it, but
maybe not always better. It's not going to be up at the top.
You're going to have to search for it because it only has 16
likes and I can't give you a direct link to it. So you can you
could shadowban people. Yeah. When you ban somebody on YouTube,
it does like weird sneaky. It's called hiding them from the channel,
which we don't really know what that does, so I wouldn't be surprised.
Sort by newest and it's around 5 hours ago. Okay. Either way,
video's dumb. Dude probably should have reached out instead of
Yeah, probably.
All right. I think I think it's just funny that more people are
drawing attention to the fact that you don't code on stream and
your code is dog. Even if you're a single developer, right? Your
code is dog and you make a bunch of comments on other people's
like coding work or their their development jobs explicitly.
Like I think that's funny to point out. Even if this guy's criticisms
are all garbage, the rest of us do actually see the rest of us
actually see like what what's going on with you. So even though
his attacks may have been like stupid,
it still just draws more attention to Pirate Software stuff and
then him responding draws more attention to his stuff. I don't
know. Read the public docs for Game Maker. Wild dude was You'll
end up eating your hat when you watch the follow-up possibly.
I'm saying I don't see any reason and I'll I'll just watch in
the next one. They might have good points, right?
Like his his global array in the thing that has to be wrong.
That has to be there has to be a way to like
if even if it's just an enim for the key, there has to be a way
to like not make it quite that spaghetti the CJ dude. Yeah. Like
I said, you're going to see a whole lot of people on YouTube
trying to pick at me
to get their 15 minutes of fame. Yep. Do you make a link to it?
You have to click on the little six hours edited.
Aha. So, that doesn't seem to do it. Oh, do I have to right click
on this and then copy link address and then do that? Is that
what does this? Ah, it does highlighted comment. There we go.
Boop. There's my comment on it. Enjoy. And I also have a a whole
argument with a whole bunch of people in the replies in there
so they can see what's going on with it. Um I I talked them through
the entire thing of why I did flu. That
that's kind of true. I think that's what happens. I don't know
if that was his point. His point was look, I have like all of
these bonafides to criticize this and then like his first criticism
is removed. Like actually totally removed. did that all in an
array because that is not normal practice to do that and it's
specifically so that you guys can reverse engineer the game and
solve the ARG. Sometimes doing bad practice has meaning which
is why I did it in that case so that you guys could do those
ARG components. And I've been saying that for years I don't know
man I don't know about this one. Also
you could have an enum. It doesn't affect the ARG. The enum the
enum in in the compiler will be the exact same thing. Right?
Right? If you had an enum naming all of those keys and then you
just like had them with those named keys that it's the same in
the compiler. They're just constants defined to those numbers.
Like it would look that when it compiles down into actual uh
like bite code or something, those will be the same statements.
There will be no difference. So it's when it's getting reversed.
I and I say that as somebody who's not worked in Game Maker and
doesn't know how it compiles down at all, but like it's an array.
You'd still be filling it with numbers, the exact same numbers.
In fact, it would just be enumerated so that you could have a
like a actual variable name to it. Anyway, the ARG solving community
around the game knows this. That's why it's done. So, it's not
a gotcha. It's just stupid. Yep. So, anyway, enjoy. When in the
world do you sleep? I haven't slept since 9:00 a.m. yesterday.
I've been working on Heartbound all day.
Nobody believes you. Nobody believes you. Nobody believes you.
Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody believes you. This game
is 10 years in progress and it's basically like a demo for the
engine. It's
Okay, check out Jesus review. Guys, in today's video, I want
to review the top contentions that not only Pirate Software had,
but a lot of his fanboys had with my video yesterday in which
I Okay, he has to eat on the magic number thing. He has to eat
[__] on the magic number thing. If he doesn't eat
on the magic number thing, he is like pirate software. He's brown
pirate software. Okay, please don't be brown pirate software.
Just eat on the magic number thing and the rest of your critiques
are fine, it seems. Ah, the alarm thing. Also, you could maybe
go, "Oh, yeah, I don't know about that one." reviewed the code
that he wrote for his game Heartbound. Now, while the video was
a stunning success in terms of can we watch the soggy serial
video next? Uh maybe there was a couple of themes that kept repeating
from detractors that I think are worth addressing in a separate
video. So let's get into it. The first claim that I saw time
and time again is that your code quality shouldn't matter if
you're a solo game dev and that code
um I would say it matters way less and that honestly if you're
spending if all of the time saved by adding an
um if all the time saved by adding subtraction if you save x
amount of time by adding some abstraction
and then the amount of time it took you to actually add it is
larger than x. So more time. You take more time to add that abstraction
than it takes then you save that. There's no reason to do it.
God, that was really [__] up for me to talk there.
What am I doing my life? H the sleep is catching up. The sleep
is catching up. I got up really early this morning. It's up today.
Okay, but what I'm saying is
just mute. What do you mean just mute? Obviously,
I don't want to take, you know, 10 minutes adding some abstraction
in, adding an enum in or adding magic, you know, or constants
in like named
if I'm not going to ever save time if I'm never going to reuse
it. If if I know I'm never going to reuse it.
We have 24 hours coding in Game Maker. No, I was not. Anyway,
quality only somehow matters if you work in a team. Now, you'd
think that if you're working on a passion project, you'd be interested
in holding yourself to the highest possible standard since
you'd be interested in getting your passion project working.
Now, I don't think he's interested in that either, so that's
confusing. But you just be interested in getting it working.
Can make your own decisions free of any corporate timeline and
not subject to demands of this. This guy's got terminal autism.
You know, they say this with such confidence as if poor code
is not going to hold you back in your own development process
and you're somehow impervious to the effects of your poor decisions
as long as you make those bad decisions yourself.
Usually, when you work with a team, you can get away with poorer
code because you won't need to deal with the consequences
of that code as you pawn it off to somebody else and work on
something totally separate. But as a solo developer, you need
to deal
This guy directly with all the tradeoffs. No, no, no, no, idiot.
As you scale, the of your code scales with the size of your organization.
If you got a 100 people who might look at that code path, the
your code is the more time it takes away from everybody else.
You are taking time away from the organization. You are burning
money for the organization. what huh that you make as you make
those decisions while you code your game or your project or your
whatever. In other words, every decision you make will either
make life easier for you or harder for you down the line. As
technical debt accumulates, you bear the entire burden of that
debt, which slows down development. Now, for those of you who
aren't technical, technical debt is a term that refers to this
is literally
dude. This guy. I'm sorry. You guys think that this is I need
to do I need to skip this section.
There has to be better [__] than this. This is This
is dog. This is dog. This is dog. This dog the extra work you're
going to need to put in down the line because you currently made
a decision that was not ideal. So you are effect delivering something
faster today only to slow down future delivery tomorrow the day
after the week after the month after etc. It's kind of like a
ball. Now this probably applies to pirate software because he
is so bad at programming andor setting himself on a timeline
that he is 10 years into his like three year or twoear development
indie game and he's not even close to finishing it. Right? So
it probably does apply where pirate software has no idea what
he's written in anywhere at any given time. That's probably the
problem here. Right. But this guy is not making good criticisms.
I disagree agree with you that this is dog, but I also don't
work in the field. So he is basically arguing that like his argument
here, the argument about like oh actually you should hold yourself
to a higher standard because you're not working with the team.
No, the whole point of the standard is that you are going to
waste the team's time if you don't apply the standard. That is
the point of the standard. It is I can't transport my knowledge
into other people's brains. So I want to I want to make sure
that this is as readable. We're going to come up with a language,
you know, we're going to speak the same language to each other
so we all understand the same things from the same symbols.
I kill myself. Oh, I had this guy on my team. I had I had a guy
like this. The issue with guys like this is while they're annoying,
this guy probably I'm guessing based on the fact that he's got
like the Monero pull requests, probably gets a lot of work done.
I'm guessing he might get a lot of work done. Okay.
So, you you deal with autist like this because they get a lot
of work done.
all in chain that's tied around your leg and every step you take
forward that ball grows and grows and grows which decreases the
velocity of your development. Now, the fact that Heartbound has
taken over 8 years to development and is still in early access
bro like the other the arguments you could have here. There are
arguments you could have. Oh, you should write following some
style guide because if you don't follow some style guide, if
you're trying to get a job eventually, you're not going to write
efficient code or effective code, sorry, for that job, right?
You're not going to write stuff that other people could read
and that would be a problem for you. Despite the fact that the
game took inspiration from Undertale, which took less time to
make and provided more content, is a reflection of the fact that
code quality is important. Wait, go read the code for Undertale
and it will stifle your development if you do not take it seriously.
And it's it's it's kind of ironic because the same people that
are trying to make excuses for poor code are the same people
that actually play the game and are expecting features to be
delivered. I don't care if his code's poor in the sense that
it doesn't impact me directly. Yeah, I might care from a technical
perspective to try to reconcile his game development experience
or his game industry experience with who he claims to be and
what he produces, but I'm not going to play his game. I don't
care for his game. And the same people that do care for his game
are the same people that say that it's okay for the game code
to be slopp in fact they're waiting on those same features that
require the game code to be clean in order to develop and do
so quickly. Now, I think that my views here can really be summarized
in I think this guy has not looked at a lot of game like a lot
of um like indie studio game code
in a dialogue that I had with Quintio when I jumped on his stream
yesterday and talked a bit more about the video. The practices
that he's employed so far are practices that I'd expect from
somebody that watched K. This guy looks like five years old.
Are we taking this guy's Does this guy at least work somewhere
cool?
Tell me this guy at least works at like Google or something.
Okay, please tell me this guy at least works at Google or something
because he looks 5 years old. Why am I taking this guy's opinion?
Academy for a week. Not somebody that's been working on a project
for eight
Claims to This guy's just a content creator that doesn't code,
isn't he?
Yeah, this guy is just a content creator that doesn't code.
Oh, no. Hold. I have to ask. who, you know, worked at Blizzard
and been around game devs or at some certain points claimed that
he's a game dev. If he just came and said, "This is what I produced.
I learned gamedev for one or two weeks, Khan Academy. I spent
two an hour or two every day." I'd say that's actually good progress.
But to come and claim that you're some like authority in the
space, you know, this is the code you've produced. To me, there's
a massive disconnect between Well, this code does look like sure
what you say you're capable of based off your background and
what you've produced. Does that make sense? Yes. And I think
that really comes down to the heart of this. Dude, I have to
look at some of the comments. My CS professor gave us a a quote
I live by to this day. You're always working on a group project.
Sometimes you're working with a 100 people or one other with
one other person. Sometimes you're working with you and you in
the future and you in the past. And don't let you in the past
write awful code. You in the present can't work with. Even by
yourself, you're always working on a group project. Simple as.
Uh I don't believe this would be the case. So there there's some
argument here for this given it's been 10 years. Okay. Like like
it can be good to write self-documented code. I would say the
better idea here is probably it's like um if you wanted to be
a professional bodybuilder,
you wouldn't like just because you're hanging out by yourself,
you don't just eat like hot dogs all the time, right? You're
not around other people. Like you you you commit to like certain
levels, certain standards. You you want to you're like looking
for a job in that field. So, you want to write good code so that
other people can look at it and and basically say, "Okay, I want
to hire this guy." This the video that Pirate responded to in
the comments or no, no, no, the other one was where you responded
unically said on Discord, "You're on the side of explaining the
code, which is dog practice of self-explaining code, which which
is dog practice." Oh, that's a comment. No, self-documenting
code is a fantastic way to operate and you should be able to
do What is up? I just clicked off the video. God damn it. Game
Maker Studio seems kind of dog though. I'll be real delivered.
I don't care if his code's poor in the sense that it doesn't
impact me directly. Yeah, I might care from a technical perspective
to try to reconcile his game development experience or industry
to an hour or two every day, I'd say that's actually good but
to come and claim that you're some like authority in the space,
you know, this is the code you've produced. To me, there is a
massive disconnect between what you say you're capable of based
off your background and what you've produced. Does that make
sense? Yes. And I think that really comes down to the heart of
this critique of that claim. And that is that Pirate Software
is constantly portraying himself as this sort of expert authority
on everything that's wrong about nothing
and uses all this hyperbolic language and associations
when in reality that's true. What he's tangibly produced is below
what you'd expect from a junior developer or even an intern.
People call me the Bob Ross of programming, which I think is
a pretty big honor because I like Bob Ross' stuff. Here, for
example, he didn't say directly, I'm Bob Ross. He said, "Everybody
thinks I'm Bob Ross of programming." What does that mean? It's
trying to paint the picture that there's a broad consensus that
you are the best developer out there and you are the go-to guy
for anything related to game programming, which is his niche.
You're a hacker. Like, that's that's where you like kind of start.
Actual hacker. An actual hacker. Not like a I'm a hacker type.
No, you're Yeah. Is gay that he represents himself as an actual
coder when he sucks.
Like an actual hacker. Yeah. My my last job was hacking power
plants for the federal government. I worked for the United States
Department of Energy. So dude, yeah. Yeah. He's a total fraud.
We've covered this. Total fraud. And you lean over to Who's that
guy? Well, that's the hacker from the That's the hacker. Three
to four man teams, man. So like we've got a team of Oh, you had
a fleet. You had like a team of dudes in suits holding laptops,
walking into restricted areas. Okay. When he says things like
this, what he's trying to paint in your mind as a viewer is that
he's some sort of unit 8200 MSAD agent riding zeroday exploits
on USBs that are snuck into Iranian nuclear facilities and that
infest and shut down the entire technical operation of that nuclear
power plant. When in reality, if you look at his LinkedIn and
reconcile it against his skill set, what he did was social engineering.
Yes, obviously. Yes, obviously. Yes, not a programmer. We've
covered this and tried to gain access to credentials and user
systems. We covered this. He was basically like So, all this
really culminates in the disconnect between who Thor plays himself
up to be and then what he can produce. It shouldn't be a surprise
to anybody that his GitHub is also totally empty. It's empty
cuz he has nothing to show for his 20 years of experience as
a veteran in the space. Now, Pirate himself also responded and
he got a bit hung up on the fact that my mouse had some variable
highlighted despite the fact that I never talked about that variable.
It's actually quite funny because I refer to this magic number
critique is every variable other than the one that he referred
Yeah. Yeah. I I pointed this out too. I pointed this out. Okay.
He He didn't even mention the sprite spark thing. Why' you Why'
you highlight the one variable that was like a a named thing?
the one the only one it didn't apply to referred to in his reply.
But skipping over that, he makes the claim that you can't define
a boolean in Game Maker because Game Maker itself doesn't have
a native boolean type in its scripting language. In other words,
it interprets Wait, he No, he didn't. He didn't say that. No,
no, no, no, no. He didn't say that. He said it doesn't matter.
He didn't say you couldn't. He said it doesn't matter. He said
it's the same.
Sorry, I'm arguing with somebody in DMs reals as booleans. Now,
to reconcile the fact that he used a boolean in his code with
what he said, I decided to do what any developer would do, and
that is I consulted the documentation. So, if you go to data
types in Game Maker, oh, look at that. You are also provided
with constants, true and false, which can always be used in your
code to prevent Oh, this is like Yeah, I literally looked this
up and I said, I don't care. Yeah, I don't I literally don't
care, right? This a gay critique. I I literally don't care. The
manual says, "This works perfectly, but don't do it because what
if we add a boolean type in the future?" Your language sucks.
You're never adding that type. You issues. Should the native
boolean type? I don't think he said you couldn't. I think he
said there was no type so it didn't matter. Hold on. We'll just
go We'll just go look at his response What was the language you
said? GML. It's called Game Maker. obviously never worked in
this language ever want to do this all stream to be honest with
you but yeah uh he's obviously never worked in this language
or with bad programmer and in reality the array of the save files
to create a workable structure high improving you a particle
I try to put delay function you can use 01 maker you cannot define
a boolean you can use 01 or true false it will doesn't do anything
none of this matters in this language the array of say you cannot
define a boolean so this is okay he says you cannot define a
boolean what he means means is is you can't say this is a boolean.
You can't say you can't statically type a boolean, but you can
dynamically type a boolean. You have the constants. It will dynamically
type it to a real number, which is weird to me. I don't know
how they're right. This is weird as
right, but it's a it's a dynamically typed language.
Just read the document. I read the documentation. I know exactly
what the documentation says. It says that don't use zero and
one even though they work perfectly because what if we add boolean
types in the future? You should use the constants because then
when you assign those when you dynamically type something with
true or false right we'll be able to dynamically type it to the
new updated boolean type and everything else will behave correctly.
Now he should do that but it doesn't matter. Doesn't make a difference
and he'd probably have to update to a new version of the language
right and then he'd have some to fix but it literally doesn't
matter. I I don't care. I think it's a pretty low-grade criticism
overall. To create a workable structure for reverse engineer
engineers trying to solve the ARG behind the game. It also saves
this out in the exact same order in the save file. You can read
about the ARG here. Oh, hold on.
Okay. It's an interpreted language. So, but it would still compile
down when you're building an executable.
It's just, bro, I hate pirate software. I hate pirate software.
I think this is like maybe if these are the best critiques you
have, you you suck. This isn't the best critique. Yeah. Probably
the readability of the array and some of the stuff he does around
like big arrays is bad. Yeah. Why would you hate someone?
Ah, cuz this guy is like useless and doesn't know it and a bunch
of people are like this guy's an expert in things. It's annoying
cuz I know some of the things he talks about and he sounds like
a this there's nothing more triggering than that short I watched.
Type be define later. So, GML defines constants true as one and
false as zero. And the documentation itself even recommends that
you use true and false instead of reals in case that association
between a boolean and a real ever gets changed to a boolean and
some other native definition of a boolean. So, in other words,
if they ever replace the aliasing of bulls for reals with bulls
for actual bulls, they recommend that you use true and false.
But we know he's not going to concede on this point or admit
the fact that he was wrong given his track record. So, let's
move on to the next
I would just say it literally doesn't matter. I don't I don't
care. Um, he should do it probably, but who cares? Another comment
that I've seen is that you've never worked with Game Maker, so
you must not know what you're talking Another equally absurd
variant of this what he's writing is not seen. But I would say
that in some of these cases, you should actually go and look
up what the thing is to to like actually know
what's going on, right? Like you should you should uh the alarms
thing I think the alarms thing is a good example where the alarms
thing now that I've looked it up and I see how the ID looks and
how you write code in Game Maker. The alarms thing I'm like I
don't I don't think that's anywhere near as bad as this guy
Maybe you could do you instead of writing five lines, you could
write three three or four lines to do a for right? I guess. But
then that assumes that you'd never need to get rid of one of
the ones in the middle. C++ or anybody who has worked with technology
or more than one programming language understands that languages
are just toolkits. Each toolkit is uniquely positioned to solve
a given problem. Now, while there might be unique features in
every toolkit, essentially there's a lot of overlap. Yeah, but
you Pirates offer should have a criticism here where you actually
explicitly failed to evaluate how this looks in GameMaker Studio
why it's like good, right? So, here, hold on.
I'm also having an argument in on the side as well.
So, like here, as you can see, you've got these alarms up here.
These alarms all correspond to the exact things over here. You
set them with a for loop and then you delete one of these, right?
Suddenly your code's wonky as, right?
Like it might be it might be nice.
Oh, actually
I wonder how this works. If you delete one of these, how if you
delete one of these, somebody was saying this earlier, that might
be the the real the real real right here. If you delete four,
what happens? Do these reumber or do they stay where they are?
Because if they stay where they are, then this is superior.
IMO. All right. Arguing with Riy? No, I'm arguing with Rita.
This is also a complete this. But this one, this is actually
like not a very good criticism
because the alarms map on one to one. I don't think there's any
advantage to going in and you like name these on the object.
I don't think there's any advantage to doing it any other way.
Why does Rita never chat? I have no idea what Rita's doing. I
just asked Rita hates Pirate Software. So I was just asking if
he saw this stuff and I I don't think the okay an integer in
one language is going to be very similar to an integer in another.
Every language is going to have for loops etc etc. So while the
actual toolkit might be different the same principles, patterns
and design decisions should apply in large part to any problem
that you're trying to solve. The only difference is the tools
that you use to solve that problem are going to be a little different.
What does that look like in practice? Take that code snippet.
Alarm 0 equals 0. Alarm 1 equals 0.
Oh no. You don't need to copy and paste that code every single
time. I'd expect an intern or somebody learning code in Khan
Academy to copy and paste. You can simply replace that all with
a for loop. So what does it say about somebody that they haven't
even considered to use a for loop for something as simple as
this? If there's something that I bro, I that could possibly
be valid. I don't think that's valid though. I don't think that's
like really super valid. I don't think this guy's like super
valid in this criticism. Not even joking. I don't think so. It's
not being able to provide more substantive feedback. If you look
at plenty of my other videos where I do a code review, I go into
line by line the GitHub repository
and break it down for my viewers, both saying what went well
and what didn't go well and how can it be improved. But Thor
didn't give me or really anybody the chance to do that with his
code because all he does is share snippets and screenshots.
You also shouldn't be representing any This guy saying that he
should open source his
bro. I He definitely can't open source his codebase in any way,
right? Because you know what would be so funny is if he open
sourced his codebase and people yo the assets and just finished
the game for him and wrote like some gay story where he his dog.
I would put time into that. I would literally donate free dev
hours to that project. Okay. He open sources his code and we
rewrite the story. Okay. You might be able to do that anyway.
Just write it where he his dog. Boom. It's actually it's going
to be the hidden ending. Okay. You saw the ARG. It's actually
going to pop out. you'll realize we were working together the
whole time. No, no, no, no. The guy in the the guy in the story
has a dog.
The the dude in the story has a dog. It's not a ferret in the
story. An entire entity made up of health, position, maybe whether
they're dead or alive, their ID, their inventory as a number
or an index into some array. That's not how you present character
models or entities in game design. And I don't even need to be
a game developer to understand that. I just watch one or two
videos of the Cherno and I already know that's the case. So hopefully
you guys found this video informative or interesting. I'm going
to now move on to other news. So unless anything new comes out
that I think I can bring my unique perspective to, I'm going
to put Pirate Software behind me and just keep moving forward.
By the way, uh the entire purpose of writing like clean code
is to clear up understanding to make it more understandable for
other people. This does not get more understandable with a for
loop. It just saves time, right? Should you do a for loop? Probably.
I'd probably do a for loop here, right? I'd probably I I don't
know if you could pass if you could pass pointers somehow, you
could write like some function that you would just do this on,
right? There's probably a way to do it that you could write a
function. You could just say clear alarms at like these indices
or something. You pass like a list of indices in or some
I don't know if there's uh oh, what do you call it?
Like spled. Can you spllay arrays or something? No, I don't know.
What do you call when you like dot dot dot in some
You know how you like an array in go in Golang? What is that
called? You basically say like flatten this.
That's doesn't matter.
You like uh a uh it's like a variable length array. You take
what is it called? Go function
haram dot dot dot. Uh dot dot dot dot. Is it just variable length
arguments? I think it's just called a variable length argument,
right? Variatic parameters. Variatic parameters. Good lord.
Yes. Variatic parameters. You guys don't know what I'm talking
about. It's fine. I'm talking to myself and I don't mind talking
to myself. Okay. What does he say about this now? Oh video, guys.
Dude, the for loop the for loop criticism is like nothing.
It's like actually nothing. I think Thor like obviously won't
take criticism, but this is not a good criticism video. Shockingly,
it's like actually just not um except possibly possibly the last
criticism where it's like, "Oh, you just have a flattened drain."
He's like, "Well, I needed to I needed to um decompile correctly."
I don't think there's any indication that he even knows how it
decompiles.
Jesus. I don't think that's a real thing. I think he's like lying
basically.
Lying maliciously. Okay. Soggy cereal was better.
Okay. Who is Soggy Cereal? Isn't this guy a loser? Didn't this
guy do this guy do like some content cop? Hold on. This guy was
like uh this guy did like an Idubbbz video and it sucked, right?
We did it on Mr. Beast. Oh, dog. No, this guy didn't suck. No,
this guy didn't suck, right? He's kind of gay, but whatever.
as a game developer who worked as game engine and tool swear
to god I'm going to go that I just had to because I grew up my
receive new content to keep need to make works as a strategy
when to boy pretentiously mocking
angrily voice
does he talk about the code anywhere or is this just a but then
this isn't like about the coding where's the stuff about the
code
special interest in YouTube's in game developer community. While
learning C++ programming, I watched the churno. Then he was my
go-to for game design. And for math physics, I just smashed my
head into a wall. However, one I always avoided was pirate software.
No, no, not the practice or like very guys. Now,
he sucks. He sucks. If you don't know him from any of that, then
you might know him as a guy who worked at Blizzard. I'm just
kidding. Now having
maple pepper
I thought this would be about
the entire with stop killing games need to make every single
consumer and
we aren't that with this vague language it would ruin live service
games we have to sunset live service games as a single player
experience the idea that suddenly you need to make every single
live service game playable single player offline no dude uh correct
yeah
I dude dude Ross looks so goofy. Uh, apparently all you wanted
was like basically a way to like view your game assets offline.
There wasn't much code to talk about. Yeah, but this this video
is just a hit piece of all the stuff we've already watched, right?
Yeah, this guy sucks. This guy sucks. This
I Yeah, I just don't I don't super care. I want to talk about
the coding stuff, but I actually don't think the coding stuff
is anywhere near as bad as anyone made it out to be. like in
terms of time saved or in terms of like how confusing the code
is. I think a bunch of people I think this is totally like propped
up.
Too bad.
The the last one the his defense for like oh the de the decompilation
is used for an ARG that is possibly totally fake. It's an exert
of a G. Yeah, link that link that right now. See you later
Link that. No,
give me that right now.
Doc say the alarms isn't back alarms isn't backed by a real array.
I can't link docs. Okay, so that means isn't backed by a real
array. But if you don't have pointers, then there's no way to
pass this object into like a function to update it, right? So
like I just Yeah, I feel like there's just nothing.
It does not hold a real GML array. So you cannot run any array
function on it or serialize it, convert it to a string. The only
operation you can run on is accessing uh a value at an index.
Yeah. So this is like some thing that's just only on this instance.
So I again I don't think this is actually bad other than maybe
the for loop. But the for loop is not oh spaghetti code. We don't
understand this. We understand exactly what's going on here.
This is not confusing code.
Can't send it in chat. Send it in uh stream chat. discord.gg/jstlk.
Giveimme gimme gimme gimme. You go to stream chat. Send it there.
I'm looking. I'm looking. And I'm looking is the last thing we
do and then I go to bed. Immediately go to bed. Probably not
actually go to bed. Probably like do some other
but get it to me. Hope all is well with you and yours. Uh yeah,
it's pretty pretty good. Thank you. Say bye.
Hope all is well with you and yours, my
Have caffeine two hours ago. True, but I'm zombie mode.
Yeah, like Gucci Jesus. I just don't know. It'll depend on how
you delete these. If you delete these and they disappear, it's
not good.
But so if you if you delete alarm four and they reumber, then
this is like this in a for loop would be bad, right? You'd be
trying to get rid of like alarm four so it doesn't proc here
I can't imagine that's the way it works,
stream game and VC. I don't know if I'm going to be keep sitting
at my computer. I might go do something else.
We'll see. We'll see.
I'm waiting on this guy to link. Oh, nice. He linked base. Thank
you very much.
Okay.
I examine pirates officers code. Yeah. Yes, it is worse than
you think. This will be a long thread. Okay. Global storyline
array. This is goofy as obviously. Wait, why does he reset it
to zero? This is the most widely known snip snippet. Decompilations
don't preserve comments. So, I also included what I what look
what it looks like in the actual code. So, why is this bad? Because
every time you want to use or change one of these values, you
have to go back to this file and look at which each of these
values can take uh take and use them accordingly.
You just use strings instead. You can just read what it says.
Hold on. What could this be? Yeah. Yeah. So, we just use uh we
just use enums. Yeah. Exactly. Boom. That's what you should do.
Look at this. Unless you've memorized all these functions. They're
they're Game Maker built-ins. Then it'll be a real pain in the
ass to read this. Oh, he This guy thinks the magic number is
bad. Hold on. Okay. Color could be a good one. Color could be
a good one to have. Although,
why wouldn't Game Maker just have these defined as colors?
Okay, hold on.
Oh, you guys can't see these. Hold on. Let me go back to this
instead of having it on the side there. Magic variables. Us programmers
want to be able to read our own code. For that, we should avoid
putting random numbers and values all over all around with no
explanation or labeling. Look at this. Unless you've memorized
all these functions, their GameMaker built-ins, then it'll be
pain in the ass to read this. Of course, this is also a shortcoming
of Game Makers. It pushes you towards this. And even the examples
they use are like that for the particle system. Yeah, cuz these
would all be different. Accelerate, thank you for the gifted
sub. The whole point of having the named uh values would be to
reuse them somewhere, but there probably is no point in reusing
them. Oh, this is this is just I as soon as I see the magic number
thing, I think you're I think you're immediately stupid. Here's
the piracy check, by the way. Pretty basic. And if you could,
of course, remove this part from demp. It's not too hard to conventionally
bypass either. This guy's 50 years of industry experience, by
the way. Okay, whatever. Don't get me wrong. Blah blah blah.
All the code I've been shown is 100% made up by me. None of it
actually exists. I totally just wrote all of it to show my
uh all the code shown by myself. Please store Thor, release my
parents. I won't publish the source code for your dumb game ever
again. Wait, was this the like day after or something? [__]
Hope this check is a real joke or a late April fool from the
devs.
Got him. Yeah, like Okay, you could like actually I think this
is the only real one that I consider
is the enums
the array. You enum the array up and then it's all good.
Wait, it's worse than you think. Going to be a long thread and
you make like 10 posts. What? I'll drop more stuff here as time
goes on. Like, make no mistake. This guy almost certainly like
sucks, right? Almost certainly sucks. But whatever. Oh, what
is this? Hold on. Hold on. Yes, we have to be more verbose. And
this is a good thing actually. It means we can look at a piece
of code that uses these and immediately tell what's going on.
Don't believe me? Just look at this code and tell me what it
does. Actually, don't. It's obviously unreadable.
Yeah. Uh, anytime you use, again, I've had llinters that just
enforce this. Like a llinter is a thing that you run over your
code to make sure you're following a style guide. So, I've had
I've had like basically, you know, scripted style guide checkers
that will say, "Oh, you're using like a switch statement without
an enumerated type." Probably a mistake.
You can like suppress the warning, but it's probably a mistake.
Like are very fun, by the way. Cool.
yesterday's secret stream was the best. Dude, people are like
trying to on this guy. This is like boring. Oh, 22 years old.
Yeah. Okay.
I'm sorry. You just won't find a lot of like older devs being
like super mad about most things except this stupid huge array.
This is like probably totally unacceptable. This like totally
And then his cope about how it decompiles is almost certainly
just cope. Anyway, all right.
think it's for the energy. Yeah, it seems kind of dumb. Yeah,
sure. The heavenlies are I mean, yeah, I'm just saying that this
is like this is how you can tell. Okay, we're starting to reach
the end times with the Pirate Software content. Okay, because
I I think these I can see these criticisms. I see people like
swinging going whole hog on this. I do not think they're very
valid criticisms. It's like uh sorry, this one is, but the magic
number thing for the particles is not.
The alarm's one is not. I don't know. Any movie recommendations?
I'm going to try to watch Eyes Wide Shut at some point. Maybe
I'll watch it tonight. It's possible. Oh, card. I forgot about
card posting. I was going to watch the card posting video of
Pirate Software DMCing. Also, there's a Will Stansel video that
Shimu made, but I'll probably just save that stuff for tomorrow.
I think we uh we didn't reach any of our goals. We have four
minutes. No, don't reach that. I'm not I'm not doing it. I'm
not doing it. I'm not doing it. Don't watch more or don't donate
for more time. I'm not doing more time right now. Okay. I'm just
not going to do it. Just not going to do it. Okay. No way. But
it was a good stream. I enjoyed the stream. I had fun. Might
check out some a little bit later. Or not. I have no idea. We'll
see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. Yeah. I don't
know if anybody disagrees even. Oh, I think I think the stop
Gabes criticism is good.
Talked about the cherry stuff much. No, we were going to do one
stream. We did it the first day and then we weren't going to
do more streams on it. So, good luck. Okay. Good luck. Yeah,
no problem. Gucci Jesus, you're welcome. I don't code, so I don't
care. I just think it's funny. I'm guessing that a lot of people
who um I'm guessing there's a lot of people who watch this stuff.
They just don't really It's like not a big deal, right?
Which is kind of fair, but I don't know. These things are like
such low-grade problems. And again, the magic number thing, that's
like for other devs. I don't think you're slowing down your your
speed that much. You might be like, realistically, the funny
thing is, okay, hold on. The realistic very funny thing is is
this might actually be
the one example where in a solo project they could be correct
because I'm guessing this guy takes so long between any coding
session to get to the next one that he probably forgets every
single thing he wrote completely right there's just no shared
knowledge of no retained knowledge of the language no retained
knowledge of like what he was doing before pirate even coding
a complex enough game yeah he probably is but it's not like a
problem it's just going to add little bits of time I don't think
this This is better.
I just don't think this is better.
But you managed to make this entertaining. Oh, well, thank you.
He did spend more time replying to comments than working on his
game. That is so true, actually.
What a loser.
Okay. All right. I will
probably end the stream here. All right, I think that's it for
us tonight.
See what's going on. Yeah, that was a good stream. I like that
stream. That was a fun stream. I enjoyed it. Thank you everyone
for being here. Good, good, good, good times. Okay, is being
based right now.
Oh, subsidized. Oh, see I think this is a this is a smart thing
to do. I'll accept the cookies.
I think I think grocerers
I don't know. I think
I think we're getting hosed right now and I think the government
needs to step in in most of the West and just be like, "Hey,
corporations, you go [__] yourselves. We're start
competing."
okay guys,
wream.
Um,
there's a chance to do some stuff in the Discord later.
We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. All right.
Have a good night, everybody.
I'll talk to y'all later.
Later.
Later. Later.
Talk to y'all later. Good night. All right. Good night. Good
night. Good night. Good night. Perhaps Barbie versus Mal round
nine. Yeah, we'll see. I talk to you later. Mal's timed out,
though, so see you guys later. Bye.